ceci explique pourquoi j'ai une voix le
canard monde cette position se trouve
sur l'homme bernard laine un jeu
d'horreur que je j'ai trouvé sur des
mesures à 1 le sorte de steam des jeux
indépendants eux 20,4
ça commence bien avant l un des petites
lampes torches comme avec nous qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que ça fait si on remplace est
cette bande sonore par genre à un champ
de matelots
tout vient s'échanger chapitre 1 de la
lettre bon alors pour le moment c'est la
dette tant d'oiseaux droite ou gauche à
léo va à droite c'est parti allez c'est
ici la grosse soirée ou quoi dites moi
tout locked va regarder ce qu'il ya
dedans obopay d'obéir
si j'étais un lumière est ce que est ce
qu on se chie littéralement dessus
didot j'ai pas vu sa mère si quelqu'un
vient je lui ferais peur avec ma voix de
canard aux nounours ok donc on a adoré
avec tout ça a l'air plutôt bien
est-ce qu'on peut s'asseoir aux jets
ainsi le nounours ok tu sais pas si tu
as fait tu as fait tu as fait une chicha
avec tes copains nounours c'est ça c'est
ça qui vient de se passer
j'suis pas leur propre nom ok très bien
tout va bien bon ben ok bah je me je me
casse on va essayer de retourner dans la
maison c'est un peintre agua où je viens
pour la soirée tu m'avais dit tout
ramener des gouvernants là j'ai ramené
les granola tu me laisses pas avoir tué
espace jeudi
est ce qu est ce que ça sent mauvais
pour nous oui oui et c'est normal
ah voilà une maison rassurantes donc
c'est juste une sorte de deux squats
what the fuck
ok mon jeu a craché je me retrouve dans
la barque de nouveau sauf que j'ai
ramassé un téléphone avec une superbe
photo de vacances
je ne sais pas bon je pense qu'après on
va pas on va aller à gauche direct en
mode basse take what a vu le focus comme
il va se prendre une loupe vitre
derrière y'a pas longtemps il y avait un
trou dans la vie de mon salon et
peut-être cet oiseau finalement à ailly
che parce que ces ide gêne à la halle à
ses chaussures il va être énervé très
bien de qui tu parles de ton pote le
désir de suivre et qui me fait peur ton
pote nounours bon en tout cas on va
aller vers la bas alors est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un ici au la population de sept
îles et d'estimer à un nounours et
peut-être un peu d'oublier un qui est le
papa de ce non sans quelques affaires à
ta ça m'a fait peur et c'est ça qui a
fait cracher jeu tout à l'heure ma go
back to close mais ah voilà
ok très bien j'ai trouvé une sorte de
livre est ce qu'il n'ya pas autre chose
de caché dans ses fougères un des oeufs
de pâques
allez on y va parce qu'ils sont pas tu
proposes ne repose tu reposes ce livre
what afobe wata funky un bruit dont sept
enfants qu'isa cheap
oh mon dieu c'est monsieur du télé à
regarder du tout marron monsieur owens
qui nous suit et bien j'ai avec papa
vient d'être papa tu veux pas finir avec
papa mais qu'est ce tu fais didier
l'assocation sur son fronton wada fac
bordel vous pouvez capituler un homme
avec une hache son caleçon sur le front
qui mangeaient beaucoup nutella nous
attaquer tour est bien bordel bon déjà
on sait qu'on ne peut pas content il me
surprendre à chaque fois c'est à chaque
fois il passe comme ça ouais on ne peut
pas compter sur teddy ted il en a rien à
et 10 me suis fait juste chauffer
les mains au feu en mode
est ce que si maintenant à maintenant je
m'étais dit mais alors du brouillard est
ce que ça a changé la donne
peut-être peut-être à l'été dit été dit
est dit c'est évident mais du brouillard
à l'été dit il s'emballe et est bordée d
en faire quoi il va tuer le wat afin
qu'ils miment s'en prendre à chaque fois
la nfb madoff vainqueur locked très bien
est-ce qu'il faut que je reprenne ce
livre auquel va tenter de reprendre le
livret de violence a sorti les gens ça
va être très très émotionnel alors ok
très bien mais passage des poids super
coq et je m'en fous je pars équilibre je
pars avec le livre je crois qu'on s'est
pris un coup de hache essieux est ce que
quelqu'un a vu lé les faits assez assez
surprenant finalement qu'ils avaient à
l'écran au sérieusement il faudrait
vraiment vraiment vraiment que je trouve
qu est ce qu il faut faire une histoire
de potes la bande l et bien cailloux
avec marc est un truc avec marquez bout
très bien les choses disparaissent comme
ça dans ce jeu sans problème
on va faire un petit tour de cartes voir
s'il n'y a pas les choses que je n'ai
pas vu auquel george et trouve un plan
de secours on va utiliser cette palette
pour faire un radeau et s'enfuir vers
faire what the fuck qu'est ce qui se
passe c est ce que je pourrais lire le
livre en portant de teddy un sage me
demande d'ailleurs ce désir ne s'est pas
présenté présente toi c'est bon il a
reposé livre l'autre devrait me pose
voilà c'est mon look peut poursuivre ok
ok qu'est ce que je dois faire
il est là il est là il est là il est pas
content avec ça je bordel de cul ce
bordel de cul devant dell de culte
bordel de cul quand il faut savoir que
là je suis en train de courir avec mon
personnage donc c'est une bonne manière
de quoi là sachant que il court à deux
kilomètres qu'est-ce que je dois ok je
sais pas où les chipeaux il et on va
aller poser le teddy on va poser le
teddy sur son petit fauteuil bien au
chaud la a et la plume et lui il est
posé il a le bon rôle dans l'histoire
quoi cet homme on le met aux mordus peut
on lui fait des petites car est oui dit
il lui faut une europe si je sûr qu'à
une question de budget marqué bouton ok
quelqu'un a des moonboots
non c'est pas grave j'ai hâte et
josselin ouanna fox qui très bien ok
c'est juste une espèce d'esprit
peut-être l'esprit du teil là je ne sais
pas j'avais le jeu vidéo allez allez
allez qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
qu'est ce qu'on fait tiens tiens les
chaussures tiens je vais lui donner les
buttes et il va me tuer comment je suis
devenu quotidien j'étais chaussures
tiens tes chaussures prolé wada faute
aux la poster il a déjà des chaussures à
sanaa pasteur ils nous avaient jusqu'ici
pas pourquoi ils tournent autour avec ce
que je dois faire mais profiteront mon
gars c'est bon on lui a donné les bulls
oui c'est la fête donc lui il donne
l'indication du chemin par d'autres
teddy tikal à poster bon je te mets au
bord du feu comme ça au petit le mans
et toi toi tout votre bon lui a donné
ses chaussures 1
au moins comme ça il a deux paires de
chaussures s'il veut marcher si vous
fait un marathon c'est comme il veut il
peut tout est permis
l'ocam et sous non mais c'est une blague
il n'avait pas écrit un petit message
sur le rocher
tu exécutes d'accord pour dire
que merde on sait qu on a été super pas
que tous les gars a marre d'ailleurs je
vais donner ses boots que vous lui oh oh
mon dieu je trouve une clé merci été
dire par contre que je te brûler comme
dans feu après un super sympa pour fêter
sa nounou mouchot up locked
hier wada focus de bordel beau
l'isolation de cette maison est plutôt
moyen on abuse par la poêle et y ait un
effet miroir là ok bon j'espère que
l'homme aux bunds ne va pas revenir nous
attaquer c'est pas excusable tourner
autour la d re fois que je rencontre
mais ces techniques d' approche plutôt
bizarre dont il m'a fait pas monsieur
vous voulez vous d'une dit que alors là
alors déjà cet homme a le nombril le
plus bizarre du monde bouge et
l'exhortent de boutons à l'interrupteur
quoi qu'est ce que veut ce espèce de
gros morceaux de wharton et voir teddy
allez salut bonnes vagues bonnes
vacances autant l'eau hors position
foetale
j'sais pas assez peut-être le joueur de
talent ou en fait finalement et la julie
c'est juste mais tout lieu quoi en
position foetale
mais ça arrive mais aussi des fois je
voulais tourner en position foetale quoi
bon enfin tu arrêtes d'apparaître comme
ça vraiment ok c'est celle de thaler
quelques on a vu aller vers la palette
alors on va aller vers la palette un an
passant faire une petite danse avec
teddy très bien cette aventure
incroyable tu étais what they déjà
disparu ttt dit est dyslexique s ouais
ça personne n'entend bon j'aime bien les
les arbres l'herbe et tout ça mais bon
comme je trouve ce qu'ils ont à chaque
fois qu'ils avaient tant pis pour moi
voilà les gens je suis désolé pas pour
cette coiffure monsieur que j'ai pas
réussi à trouver la suite enfin je suis
désolé aussi pour cette coupure
j'ai juste pas trouvé ce qu'il fallait
faire par la suite bon ça arrive voilà
et là vous allez être un million à me
dire mais fallait faire comme si un qe3
une merde je me sentir bien bête tout ce
que vous aurez raison
en tout cas merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo on se retrouve très bientôt dans
une nouvelle vidéo sur garry's mod
parce que là le banc quand je n'aurais
pu déboucher ce sera un peu mieux et
merci beaucoup d'avoir gagné cette vidéo
restez comme vous êtes parce que vous
êtes top et aujourd'hui on va faire un
check de coude à l'échec du coude et
d'ailleurs fait eh oui
je souris verte ou pure web à partir sur
un coup de chaîne apparemment c'est
juste pour apporter en fait t'as vu du
ciel bas toi et voilà le combat des
hommes les plus